BUYLEESA.COM TODAY. YOU NEED
THIS BED.
>> Tucker: MORE POLITICIANS
IN CALIFORNIA ARE ENDORSING
EFFORTS TO DIRECTLY RESIST
FEDERAL LAW.
LAST WEEKEND OAKLAND MARY
LIBBY SCHAAF WARNED
RESIDENTS OF ICE RAIDS
ALLOWING DANGEROUS CRIMINALS
TO ESCAPE.
GAVIN NEWSOM WHO HOPES TO
BECOME THE GOVERNOR SOON
ONCE JERRY BROWNE LEAVES
CALLING ON OTHER GOVERNORS
TO DO THE SAME THING THAT
WILL MAKE THE STATE BETTER.
OF COURSE THEY WILL.
GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
MR. ALLEN, THANKS FOR COMING
ON.
>> THANKS SO MUCH, TUCKER.
PLEASURE BEING ON.
>> Tucker: I HAVEN'T LIVED
IN CALIFORNIA FOR A WHILE.
I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER.
DOES ANYONE NOTICE THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS AN
OPEN REBELLION AGAINST THE
UNITED STATES?
IS THAT NOTED OUT THERE.
>> YOU KNOW, CALIFORNIANS
ARE ALL SCRATCHING HEIR THEY
HAD
HED
HEADAT WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
GAVIN NEWSOM THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE MEDIA
REPORTS ORDINARY
CALIFORNIANS ARE ABSOLUTELY
SHOCKED WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THE STREETS OF CALIFORNIA.
>> Tucker: SO, I MEAN, WHAT
DO YOU THINK THE CORE
PROBLEM IS?
I MEAN, CALIFORNIA WAS ONCE
THE GREATEST STATE IN THE
UNION.
PEOPLE CAME FROM ALL OVER
THE WORLD TO LIVE THERE, I
MEAN, LOOK OUGHT POPULAR
MEDIA FROM 50 YEARS AGO.
PEOPLE SANG ABOUT MOVING TO
CALIFORNIA.
PEOPLE ARE FLEEING
CALIFORNIA NOW?
WHAT CHANGED DO YOU THINK?
>> WHAT CHANGED IS DECADES
OF THE DEMOCRATS RUNNING
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
3 OF THE LAST 40 YEARS
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATS
CONTROLLED BOTH HOUSES OF
THE STATE LEGISLATURE AND
JERRY BROWN AND HIS FATHER
HAS CONTROLLED FOR THE LAST
24 OF THE 50 YEARS.
TAXES GO UP.
BUSINESSES LEAVE, OUR PEOPLE
LEAVE.
AS A MATTER OF FACT 243,000
CALIFORNIA ANS LEAVING
TAKING $8 BILLION WITH THEM.
NOW WE ARE SEEING OPEN
THE CRIMINAL ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF CALIFORNIA OPENLY
THREATENING CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES IF YOU FOLLOW
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION LAW, HE
IS GOING TO PROSECUTE YOU
AND, OF COURSE, HAVE YOU
HEARD OF LIBBY SCHAAF, IT'S
GETTING WORSE NOW.
>> Tucker: TELL ME ABOUT THE
QUARTER MILLION CALIFORNIANS
WHO HAVE LES NUT PAST SEVEN
YEARS U THOSE ARE NORMAL
MIDDLE CLASS PEOPLE, RIGHT?
OUT KIND THAT YOU FORM A
SOCIETY AROUND.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I CAN
TELL YOU VERY PERSONALLY
THESE ARE MY PARENTS.
MY PARENTS HAVE LEFT OUT
STATE.
MY BROTHERS LEFT THE STATE.
MY BEST FRIEND NOW LIVES IN
TEXAS WHERE HE DOUBLED OUT
SIZE OF HIS HOUSE, DOUBLED
OUT SIZE OF HIS BUSINESS AND
PAYS NO STATE INCOME TAX.
I'M ALSO AN INVESTED ADVISOR
TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLYMAN, CAN I TELL YOU
MY CLIENTS ALL STARTED IN
CALIFORNIA.
NOW IN 22 DIFFERENT STATES
ARRANGED OUT NATION.
>> Tucker: I MEAN, DO THE
PEOPLE WHO RUN THE STATE
HAVE ANY -- DO THEY KNOW
THIS?
DO THEY PAY ANY ATTENTION?
I THOUGH YOUR TECH SECTOR IS
DOING WELL AND MORE MORE
PEOPLE THAN EVER.
YOU ARE BOOMING ON EITHER
END.
ARE THEY WORRIED ABOUT THE
MIDDLE CLASS LEAVING.
>> IT'S AS IF THEY LIVE IN A
BUBBLE.
THEY ABSOLUTELY DO NOT SEE
THIS.
IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE.
IF YOU WERE GAVIN NEWSOM THE
FORMER MAYOR OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND YOU HAD MAPS
YOU HAVE HUMAN WASTE SO
PEOPLE COULD NAVIGATE
THROUGH YOUR CITY.
HURON DER MICK
BYRON DER MICK
BY HN DER MICK
BY HERDER MICK
BY HER DR MICK
BY HER DERMICK
MICK NEEDLES AND INJECTIONS
CENTERS OPENING IN JULY IN
SAN FRANCISCO IT MIGHT MAKE
SENSE TO LOOK THE OTHER WAY
AT THE FACTS.
THAT REALLY IS THE ONLY
EXPLANATION IN CALIFORNIA.
HIGHEST POVERTY IN THE
NATION.
ONE IN FIVE CALIFORNIANS
LIVING BELOW OUT POVERTY
LINE.
HIGHEST HOMELESSNESSED IN
THE NATION.
AND I MEAN THE NUMBERS GO ON
AND ON.
>> Tucker: THEY DESTROYED